Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在切入今天的节目之前，我想快速和大家分享一件目前正在发生的激动人心的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是无休止地用时间换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“向持续收入冲刺挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. Without a memory and dread Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用于你。丽莎本人还将亲自送出丰厚的奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一辅导一小时的机会。想了解更多吗？你当然想。请访问我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会告诉你所有的详情。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。如果你正准备成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南吧。在记忆与恐惧之中 欢迎收kommen来到“有抱负的心理学家播客”（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。
Hope you are okay and enjoying the festive season so far if you're listening to this in December. So I think that it is fair to say it can feel pretty tricky to get a relevant experience, especially what many consider the golden nugget of assistant psychologist experience in this day and age. It was certainly tricky even in my day, let alone now. So when I was on socials recently, it really took my attention that one employer is doing something that seems a little bit different in terms of the way they recruit and the way they interview people for these posts. And we're talking about contextual admissions, which is something big and important in the world of psychology right now. So it's lovely to see it coming out in assistant non-qualified positions as well as in training places and beyond.
希望你一切都好，如果收听这期节目时正值12月，祝你节日季过得愉快。我觉得可以肯定地说，想要获得相关的经验感觉相当棘手，尤其是对于现在许多人视为“黄金敲门砖”的助理心理学家经验而言。即使在我们那个年代这也很棘手，更不用说现在了。所以，我最近在社交媒体上看到一件事，真的吸引了我的眼球：有一家雇主在招聘和面试这些岗位时，采取了一些看似不太一样的做法。我们谈论的是“情境招生/录用”（contextual admissions），这是当今心理学界一个重大而重要的话题。所以看到这种做法不仅出现在培训名额及更广泛的领域，还出现在助理等非资深职位上，真是令人欣慰。
So it's a guest episode today. It's our first trio episode. So I hope you find it really useful. And I'll look forward to catching you on the other side. Welcome along to today's episode of the Aspiring Podcast. I really want to welcome and introduce you to Dr. Alistair Teague and Anna Lee. Hi, guys. Hi. Hi there. Thank you so much for coming along. and as I've mentioned in the intro
所以今天是一期嘉宾访谈节目。这是我们的首期三人访谈。希望你会觉得它非常有用，我期待在节目后半部分与大家见面。欢迎来到今天的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我热烈欢迎并向大家介绍阿利斯泰尔·蒂格博士（Dr. Alistair Teague）和安娜·李（Anna Lee）。嗨，各位。嗨。嗨，大家好。非常感谢你们能来。正如我在引言中
already there's a couple of reasons why I wanted to bring you both along here. So Alistair caught my attention on Twitter actually because you were part of what looks like quite a pioneering recruitment process in your trust and that's a recruitment process for assistant psychologists that Anna has gone through so I thought it'd be really really interesting to have a chat about that and potentially the future of recruitment in psychology would be a really nice idea but also it's always lovely to hear a little bit about both of you and your journeys to being where you're at right now so if we could start with that um initially that would be brilliant so um Anna
已经提到过的，我想把你们两位请到这里来主要有几个原因。实际上，阿利斯泰尔是在推特上吸引了我的注意力，因为你们信托基金会似乎正在进行一项颇具开创性的招聘流程，而安娜正是经历了这个招聘流程才来到这里的。所以我觉得，聊聊这个话题，探讨一下心理学招聘的未来，会是一个非常棒的主意。同时，了解一下你们两人的背景，以及你们是如何走到今天这一步的，也总是让人喜闻乐见。所以，如果我们能从这一点开始，
let's go with you first if that's okay could you tell us a little bit about how you know how you got to be where you're at right now yeah so absolutely so I did my undergraduate degree in straight psychology at the University of Liverpool in my sort of gap just before I did my undergrad I went out into Nepal and did some volunteer work working in schools and orphanages so that was very much before I'd probably realized it was obviously a very sort of psychological focus um so then within my undergrad I had sort of a broad range of um modules but forensic psychology was the one I was most interested by so um I went on to do a master's in that um which I then began working in a secure psychiatric unit for about a year and a half I think so I did bank work so I was able to do work on the medium secure the low secure and the
那就太棒了。那么，安娜，如果你不介意的话，我们先从你开始。能跟我们讲讲你是如何走到今天这一步的吗？好的，没问题。我在利物浦大学（University of Liverpool）攻读了纯心理学本科学位。在读本科之前的那段间隔年里，我去了尼泊尔做了一些志愿工作，在学校和孤儿院帮忙。那时候我可能还没意识到这其实带有很强的心理学导向。后来在读本科期间，我选修了广泛的模块，其中法医心理学是我最感兴趣的。所以
psychiatric intensive care unit um which I think is it was really really good choice actually in the end doing bank work because you get such more of a broad experience and then I started sort of making the jump to applying for assistant posts and having worked in a very forensic field for about a year and a half I'd basically just decided I wanted to try something a little bit different and neuropsychology was something that I was very interested in in my undergrad but I'd always maybe thought it was a little bit further out of my reach but actually when it sort of came down to it and reading the job spec and then going sort of through the interview process and then sort of getting and being successful and getting a job as an assistant psychologist in neuropsychology the support that you actually get once you're there um suddenly that barrier wasn't really um as yeah as much of a barrier in these anymore so yeah so I sort of went through a very forensic
我接着去读了这方面的硕士学位。之后，我在一个安全精神病院工作了一年半左右。我做的是兼职流动护工（bank work），所以我有机会在中度安全病房、低度安全病房以及精神病重症监护室工作。
route but um ended up in neuro at the moment which I'm really really enjoying. Oh thank you so much for sharing could you tell us a little bit about what you do within your day-to-day role, if that's okay, Anna? Yeah, absolutely. So currently I'm in an outpatient service, so any neurological deficit in the brain. So it can be from past experiences, trauma, physical ailments. So it's essentially a big sort of pressure build up over time. So it's providing psychological therapy to those individuals. At the moment, I'm currently facilitating an online course. So it's a psychoeducational course, basically just reviewing sort of need management strategies for them to try and help manage their seizures and just educating them a bit more about the condition. It sounds amazing. And I'm sure you're such a useful resource for the team, but also for the clients you serve.
回想起来，选择做流动护工真的是一个非常非常好的决定，因为你能获得如此广泛的经验。后来我开始着手申请助理心理学家的岗位。在法医领域工作了一年半之后，我基本上只是决定想尝试点稍微不同的东西。神经心理学是我在读本科时就很感兴趣的一个领域，但我以前总觉得它有点遥不可及。但实际上，当真正去阅读岗位说明、经历面试流程、成功获得神经心理学助理心理学家的职位，并且感受到入职后实际获得的各项支持时……突然之间，那种曾经的障碍似乎就不再是那么大的障碍了。所以，是的，我虽然走了一条非常偏向法医的路线，
Thank you so much for sharing um Alistair could you tell us a little bit about your background and how you got to be where you are please yeah yeah of course um so yeah I suppose I I didn't fall into clinical psychology till relatively late on I similarly I did an undergrad at Liverpool um a fair while before and I did um and I was I was interested in the crowd behaviour side of things. There was also a bit of forensics I was interested in there. I just didn't really know what I wanted to do at that stage. I was fortunate enough to be able to afford to do a master's.
但目前最终来到了神经心理学领域，而且我真的非常非常享受这份工作。哦，非常感谢你的分享。安娜，如果可以的话，你能跟我们简单聊聊你的日常工作内容吗？好的，没问题。目前我在一个门诊部工作，负责处理大脑中的各种神经系统功能缺损。这些缺损可能源于过去的经历、创伤或身体疾病。这本质上是一种压力随时间推移而不断积累的过程。因此，我们的工作就是向这些患者提供心理治疗。目前，我正在协助开展一个在线课程。这是一个心理教育课程，基本上就是帮助患者复习一些应对管理策略，试图协助他们控制癫痫发作，并向他们普及更多关于这种疾病的知识。听起来太棒了。我相信你不仅是团队中非常有用的资源，也是你所服务的客户的重要支持。
I saw my car and my family were able to support me to a degree. So I ended up doing performance psychology at Edinburgh. I played a fair bit of sport, I'm considering sports psychology, considering PE teaching and I sort of thought I wanted something quite broad. It was only really when I was up there that I met a lot of different people doing different things you know I had people from business, people from the arts, people from sport and a good friend of mine Sophie she was going down the clinical route. And it was only as we were talking a bit more about that, I was like, well, actually, I could go down that route. And the sports psychology side seems quite hard.
非常感谢你的分享。阿利斯泰尔，请问你能给我们讲讲你的背景以及你是如何走到今天这一步的吗？好的，当然可以。嗯……我想我涉足临床心理学的时间相对较晚。同样地，我早些年在利物浦大学读了本科，当时我对群体行为方面的东西很感兴趣。我也对法医心理学有一点兴趣。那时候我真的不知道自己想做什么。我很幸运，经济条件允许我去读硕士。
The clinical psychology side seems quite hard, too, but I might get paid to do it. And it seems a bit easier to get the placement. So I suppose big thanks to Sophie for pointing me in the right direction, really. And then, yeah, then I was on the treadmill trying to find AP posts. Sort of a teenager going into my early 20s, I'd done a fair bit of data entry. I'd done some reception work and administrative work in the NHS you know my mum was a nurse in the in the NHS and worked her way up to management so I was quite privileged in terms of being able to be a bit of an NHS brat and find my way into bank jobs I also worked for
我卖掉了自己的车，家人也在一定程度上给予了我支持。因此，我最终去爱丁堡大学（Edinburgh）攻读了运动心理学。我当时打了不少运动，考虑过运动心理学，考虑过体育教学，而且我觉得自己想找一个范围比较广的领域。直到我在那里遇到了许多做着不同事情的人——你知道的，有来自商业界的人、艺术界的人、体育界的人——我的一位好朋友索菲（Sophie）当时正沿着临床心理学的方向发展。随着我们深入探讨这个话题，我心想：“其实，我也可以走这条路。”运动心理学的方向看起来挺难的。
Sure Start sort of the labour initiative which became First Steps and that was my in um so i only had one ap interview uh for my before getting my first post and that was in first step psychological service that was in stoke it was outside where i lived so they didn't know me but i was really fortunate to know the service and the type of people that i'd be working with that temporary contract ended couldn't get another ap post did an audit for a homelessness team for a couple of months and then um i suppose found myself in uh applying for a neuropsychology job down in oxford and that's when i found a bit more of a mix of what i liked you know um i didn't realize sort of that psychological and medical model and how that worked together or sometimes
临床心理学方向看起来也挺难，但我可能还能因此拿到薪水，而且好像更容易申请到实习。所以，我觉得真的要非常感谢索菲把我指引到了正确的方向。然后，我就开始在寻找助理心理学家（AP）岗位的“跑步机”上日复一日地奔忙。从十几岁步入二十出头的年纪里，我做过不少数据录入工作，在NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）做过前台接待和行政工作。你知道的，我妈妈是NHS的一名护士，一路晋升到了管理层。所以，作为一名“NHS土生土长的小孩”，我在寻找流动岗位方面享有一定的特权，我也为自己找到了一条通往这些岗位的路。我还为
trying to pull them together um yeah and it was from there that i really sort of that psychological and medical model and how that worked together or sometimes trying to pull them together. Yeah. And it was from there that I really sort of felt this is definitely where I want to go. Cause even that point I was like, is this for me? You know, I wasn't sure. I got on at Manchester, trained at Manchester, really enjoyed that. Did, did an older adult placement at Salford Royal um and then never really left um end up doing the specialist placement there and since that time I've worked a bit in community neuro rehab I've worked within the epilepsy service and also non-epileptic attack disorders
“Sure Start”（工党倡议的项目，后来演变为“First Steps”）工作过，这就是我的切入点。所以我只参加过一次AP职位的面试，就拿到了我的第一份工作，那是斯托克（Stoke）的“First Steps”心理服务项目。那地方在我住处的外围，所以他们虽然不认识我，但我很幸运地了解这项服务以及我将要共事的同类人群。那份临时合同到期后，我没能找到另一个AP岗位，于是为流失人口/无家可归者团队做了几个月的审计工作，然后……我想，我发现自己在
and then I spent a good couple of years working in major trauma, so major physical trauma, including spinal injuries, brain injuries. And then following on from that, I got a consultant neuropsychologist post, working mainly in acute neuro rehab, doing a little bit of outpatients, but then I suppose overseeing people working in stroke rehab, major trauma. And then just, I suppose, as an an aside as a result of i suppose my experience in neuropsychology and spinal um as of next week um i'm going out to ukraine with the world health organization and helping set up um a spinal cord injury and brain injury unit in in reavener so i suppose that's going to be a bit of short-term work i'm going to do a few stints out there but
牛津申请了一份神经心理学的工作，也就是在那里，我发现了一种更符合我兴趣的结合点。你知道的……我以前没有意识到这种心理学模式和医疗模式是如何协同工作的，或者说有时是如何试图将它们结合在一起的……是的，也就是从那里开始，我真的……这种心理学与医疗模式的结合以及它们如何协同工作，或者有时如何试图将它们融合在一起，就是从那时起，我真的觉得这绝对是我想要追求的方向。因为甚至在那之前我还纳闷：这真的适合我吗？说实话，我不确定。后来我被曼彻斯特大学录取，在曼彻斯特完成了培训，我真的很享受那段经历。我在索尔福德皇家医院（Salford Royal）做过老年人心理健康的实习，然后就真的没有离开过——最终在那里完成了专家实习。在那之后，我在社区神经康复中心工作过一段时间，在癫痫服务部门工作过，也处理过非癫痫性发作障碍（NED）的相关工作。
i suppose it's just for for the pod really that there's a number of different experiences I've got over the years that have led me to where I am and what I'm going to do in the next six months that I feel really grateful for really so hopefully that gives a bit of a hopefully a snapshot of some of the things I've done. Yeah it really does and it really shows the diversity of this career of ours but also you know the privilege to be able to go out to the Ukraine and help people specifically at this time. You know, not not an easy thing to do, but I'm sure it will be richly rewarding for you and for the people that you'll be working with as well. Yeah, I think so. You know, at this moment in time it's a bit of an unknown quantity um there's a lot of work to be done I'm looking forward to just getting my feet on the
接着，我在重大创伤部门工作了整整好几年，涉及重大身体创伤，包括脊髓损伤和脑损伤。在那之后，我获得了咨询神经心理学家的职位，主要在急性神经康复中心工作，做一点门诊工作，但随后我还负责监督中风康复和重大创伤康复领域的工作人员。再然后，我想……由于我在神经心理学和脊髓损伤方面的经验，从下周开始，我将随世界卫生组织（WHO）前往乌克兰，协助在里夫内（Rivne）建立一个脊髓损伤和脑损伤病房。我想这是一项短期工作，我要去那里出差几次，
ground and getting understanding of it and then from that point I think going into January February and March I've got a bit more of an idea of what needs to be done and what we could recommend you know brilliant do you know how long you'll be there for? I'm contracted till the end of March, but I'm doing like a week before Christmas and then two weeks in January, two weeks in February, two weeks in March and then do my NHS job in between. OK, so you're flying back and forth? Yeah. Yeah. OK, well, I hope it goes brilliantly well. Thank you. I appreciate that. You know, really hoping that great things are able to happen due to your work so um yeah
但对这个播客来说，这些年我积累了许多不同的经历，它们造就了今天的我，也指引着我未来六个月要做的事情，对此我真的感到非常感激。所以希望这能大致勾勒出我所做过的一些事情的剪影。是的，确实如此，它真正展现了我们这个职业的多样性，同时也展现了能够前往乌克兰并在这样一个特殊时期直接帮助人们的特权。你知道，这绝非易事，但我确信这对于你以及你将要共事的人们来说，都会带来丰厚的回报。是的，我也这么认为。眼下这还是一个未知数，有很多工作要做。我很期待能双脚踏上
recruitment processes in psychology could you give us a little bit of an overview of what they were like before if that's okay yeah i suppose from from from my side from a manager side you know we not change what we do particularly you know um the job description and person spec was usually pretty standard but as the more you look at it it feels a bit more exclusive when you see it with through a different lens you know there's often an onus on achieve this in your undergrad oh have you done a master's that's more points um have you got this experience as an assistant in psychology well that's more points um so it it felt it felt quite academic based and i suppose didn't take into um into account contextual factors which are you know i think more and more
那片土地，去了解那里的情况。从那个节点开始，我想进入1月、2月和3月时，我对需要做什么以及我们可以提出什么建议会有更清晰的想法。太棒了！你知道你要在那里呆多久吗？我的合同签到了3月底，但我打算在圣诞节前去一周，然后在1月呆两周，2月呆两周，3月呆两周，其余时间则穿插着做我在NHS的工作。哦，所以你要两边飞？对的。是的。好吧，祝一切顺利！谢谢，我很感激。真心希望通过你的工作能够带来伟大的成果。那么，
in clinical psychology we're talking about and i think that's where you know in on social media and with some colleagues who are sort of driving the forefront of that sort of stuff we really wanted to think about changing that um in addition to that in the last couple of years myself and uh a couple of my colleagues Georgia Dunning in particular and Nadine Merzer we've been looking at ethnicity in neuropsychology referrals but also staffing and you know we recognize that our staffing at Salford was not representative of the population we were serving and actually that's that's really important to do so that was I suppose some of the setting conditions for us to evaluate it and then I was kind of made aware that Health Education England had been given or worked towards
关于心理学的招聘流程，如果可以的话，你能给我们简单介绍一下以前的情况是怎样的吗？好的，我想从我作为管理者的角度来看，我们以前并没有特别去改变我们的做法。你知道的，职位描述和个人能力要求通常都相当标准。但当你用不同的视角去看待它时，就会发现它其实具有更多的排他性。你知道的，职位要求往往会强调：在你的本科阶段要取得这个成就哦，你读过硕士吗？那能加分；你有没有做过心理学助理的经验？那又能加分。所以，它感觉非常基于学术背景，并且没有考虑到
getting a pot of money and that was explicitly aimed at improving access for aspiring clinical sites from perhaps underrepresented or disadvantaged backgrounds to get paid experience? Because again, that's the dilemma is there's a lot of honorary posts and some of them exploitative, some of them aren't AP posts at all. And then how do you get experience without getting experience? So I suppose what we did is try to whack in an application, see how it went, and then following on from that, it really gave us a bit of an incentive and legitimized us trying to change what we were doing for the better
情境因素——而这正是我们在临床心理学中越来越多地讨论的内容。我认为这也是为什么在社交媒体上，以及与一些正在推动这方面变革的同事们一起，我们真的很想考虑去改变这一点。除此之外，在过去几年里，我和我的几位同事——特别是乔治娜·邓宁（Georgia Dunning）和娜丁·默泽（Nadine Merzer）——一直在研究神经心理学转诊中的种族问题，同时也关注员工队伍的构成。我们认识到，我们在索尔福德的员工队伍并不能代表我们所服务的整体人口，而这其实是非常重要的一点。所以我想，这些就是促使我们对现状进行评估的一些背景条件。然后我了解到，英国健康教育局（Health Education England）已经筹集到或正在努力筹集
thank you it's a really useful overview um so how how has it been going for you and how long have you been doing it for um yeah so I think we've got two strands to this really like we've got we often undergrad offer undergrad placements to a local university and i think that was a nice little trial run to start asking them to not talk about what grades they got at a level to not talk about how they've been doing in their first year and second year but to talk about their contextual factors personal or second-hand experience of stuff their values you know sort of things that make them them rather than what the person spec says or what they think the job should be um so we've probably been doing that and increasing that over two three four years and then since i think we got the funding for the post-anazine um maybe last
一笔资金，这笔资金明确旨在改善来自代表性不足或弱势背景的有志临床心理学人才获得带薪经验的机会。因为，这又回到了那个两难困境：有很多无薪岗位，其中一些具有剥削性质，有些甚至根本算不上真正的AP岗位。那么，在没有经验的情况下，你又如何能获得经验呢？所以我想我们所做的事，就是尝试提交一份申请，看看进展如何。在那之后，这确实给了我们很大的动力，也让我们试图朝着更好方向去改变现状的努力变得名正言顺。
september um and so from that point myself and my colleague selena making um really got on the case of it um it took quite a while to to pull the various elements to the uh the recruitment process together but again because we've been given new funding it legitimized it and we were then able to engage with our equality diversity and inclusion team with the recruitment team itself with a few a few other people to try and i suppose provide a bit more of a rounded perspective do the hard yards to make it easier further down the line because sometimes you just don't have the time to change processes um so i think for us it was it was really useful to do and now we're trying to see how it cascades out you know most of our assistant posts are adopting a very similar process and we're trying to think about things in a different way when it comes to qualified posts as well. When we're trying to make changes specifically in the NHS there can be a lot of additional
谢谢你，这是一个非常有用的概述。那么，这个项目进展得怎么样了？你们开展多久了？是的，所以我想我们目前实际上在做两条线。一方面，我们通常会向当地一所大学提供本科实习岗位，我认为这是一个很好的小型试验，开始要求他们不要谈论自己在A-level（英国高中课程）中考了什么成绩，不要谈论他们在第一年和第二年的表现如何，而是要谈论他们的情境因素、个人或间接的生活经验以及他们的价值观。换句话说，是谈论那些让他们成为“他们自己”的特质，而不是对照职位说明去堆砌要求，也不是去猜想这份工作“应该”是什么样子的。
paperwork and meetings and meetings to have meetings and it can all be quite stressful and even knowing the right people to call can be really difficult. How did you know HR and recruitment respond to your requests to think about changing things? Yeah, it's a bit slow at times. Anyone who's worked in the NHS knows that there's a lot of bureaucracy at times and a lot of processes. But I think because Salford were quite keen to improve diversity across the board and were quite, I suppose suppose trendsetters in a number of ways management were on board so as soon as management were on board we were like well actually
我们大概已经这样做了两、三年、四年，并且在不断推进。自从我们为安娜等人的岗位争取到资金之后——大概是去年9月份吧，我和我的同事塞莉娜·麦金（Selena Makin）就真正全力投入到这项工作中了。将招聘流程的各个要素整合在一起花了不少时间，但同样，由于我们获得了新的资金支持，这让我们的做法变得合理化。我们随后得以与我们的平等、多元与包容（EDI）团队、招聘团队本身以及其他一些人进行沟通，试图提供一个更全面的视角，在前期付出艰苦的努力，从而让后续的流程变得更轻松。因为有时你真的没有时间去改变流程。所以，我认为对我们来说，这样做真的非常有用，而现在我们正试图看看如何将这种模式推广开来。我们大多数的助理岗位都在采用非常相似的流程，当涉及到正式编制岗位时，我们也在尝试用不同的方式去思考问题。
well let's run with this um so yeah i think it was a bit slow at times and you know arranging meetings and gathering information took took time and for myself and Selina in particular finding time in our diary to do this or getting permission to move things or do different things was also a bit of a challenge but I suppose what we're seeing now is people are starting like yourself hearing about what we're doing getting in touch via email and we've kind of done quite a lot of the work already so they don't have to they've kind of got here's the precedent can we try and replicate this which is which is great for us you know we're we're changing practice incredible it's very inspirational as well so
当我们在NHS内部尝试做出具体改变时，可能会遇到大量额外的文书工作、会议，以及为了开会而开会的会议，这都相当令人沮丧，甚至连知道该给谁打电话都非常困难。人力资源部门（HR）和招聘部门对你们提出改变现状的要求作出了怎样的反应？是的，有时进展确实有点慢。任何在NHS工作过的人都知道，这里有时充斥着大量的官僚主义和繁琐流程。但我想，由于索尔福德一直非常热衷于全面提升多元化，并且在许多方面可以说是潮流引领者，管理层对此是非常支持的。所以一旦管理层表示支持，我们就顺水推舟地说：“那好，我们就按这个干吧！”
well done to you and to the people that are in your team as well um how was it for you then Anna spotting this application this um job advert that probably looked a little bit different than the ones that you'd been seeing beforehand yeah absolutely that's it I think um initially I'm not sure I'd realized about the following stages but first if I was to think just about the written written application firstly sort of giving emphasis on drawing on your personal experiences and how that sort of informs your own psychological skills and knowledge I think that actually a night of quite like a hot topic of psychologists and sort of therapists not having
所以，是的，虽然有时候进展有点慢，安排会议和收集信息也需要时间，但对于我和塞莉娜来说，尤其是在我们的日程表中挤出时间来做这件事，或者获得批准去调整安排、尝试不同的事情，也是一个小小的挑战。不过我想，我们现在看到的是，人们开始像你一样，听说了我们在做的事情，通过电子邮件主动联系我们，而我们实际上已经做了相当多前期准备工作，所以他们不必从头开始。他们可以直接拿到“先例”，问：“我们能复制这个吗？”这对我们来说太棒了，我们在真正改变行业惯例。太不可思议了，这也极具启示意义。所以
their own personal challenges um but actually how these things can actually make how you approach situations more effective um so that sort of stigma around it i think it was really good to to see something that was sort of a bit more representative of actually drawing on your personal experiences and how you can use that to inform your practice um so yeah i think with um other posts i hadn't really i'd sort of focused on my skills i knew i had um and positives and relating them to the job spec but i'd never really thought about drawing on my personal experiences when obviously there's so much so many rich skills that you obtain outside of work and outside of clinical settings that you can absolutely transfer into clinical settings and use these sort of real life experiences to inform your approach so
向你以及你团队里的人致敬！安娜，当你发现这份申请——这份可能看起来与你之前看到的招聘广告有些不同的工作广告时，你的感受如何？是的，完全是这样。我想……最初我可能并没有意识到后续的各个阶段，但首先，如果只看书面申请本身，它强调的是借用你的个人经验，以及这些经验如何塑造你自身的心理学技能与知识。我认为，这实际上是心理学家和治疗师群体中一个相当热门的话题——即他们自己是否有过个人挑战。但实际上，正是这些经历，能够让你的应对方式变得更加有效。因此，打破围绕这方面的污名化，看到有这样一份招聘启事，能够更加真实地代表“借鉴个人经验并将其应用到实践中”这一理念，真的感觉非常好。
I also think it made me massively think outside the box in terms of how I responded. So I think I spoke about things that had it not asked me to explicitly draw on these experiences, I definitely wouldn't have mentioned in an application. So, for example, something to do with, like, the interdependence between health and mental health, so physical health and mental health. So I think I drew on secondary experiences of of supporting individuals with um physical disabilities and in and how you sort of witness
所以，是的，对于其他岗位，我以前基本上只会关注我自认为拥有的技能，以及与职位说明相匹配的亮点，但我从未真正想过去借鉴自己的个人经验。明明在工作和临床环境之外，你能够获得如此丰富、如此多的技能，你可以完全将它们转移到临床环境中，利用这些真实的生活经验来指导你的方法。
the process of being passed around and and issues with diagnosis and medical gaslighting and things like that um and that completely what I realize now has massively informed how I approach the role I'm in at the moment where the diagnosis the process of getting a diagnosis of non-epileptic attack disorder is so long and often individuals are sort of gone through a completely long and medical route of it potentially being epilepsy and lots of other things so thinking sort of reflecting back to my application drawing on that experience of of my own personal experience in um in my family and things like that of seeing um the process of medical gas slicing and and long long-term diagnosis and what that does to an individual yeah massively I I definitely draw on that now so that's that's one major thing that I think
我也觉得，这极大地拓展了我的思路，让我跳出固有框架去思考该如何回应。我想，如果它没有明确要求我借鉴这些个人经验，我绝对不会在申请中提及某些事情。例如，关于健康与心理健康之间的相互依存关系——也就是身体健康与心理健康的关系。因此，我想我借鉴了支持患有身体残疾的个人的次要经验，以及你如何见证被医疗系统当作皮球一样踢来踢去的过程、诊断中遇到的问题以及医疗上的“煤气灯操纵”（medical gaslighting，指医务人员否定或贬低患者症状的现象）等等。
probably the first thing that I noticed about um the application that was different. Brilliant and it's just so important isn't it you know in terms of this career of ours reflecting doesn't suddenly happen you know when you're on training or when you're qualified you need to be able to be doing it and practicing it and, you know, honing your skills in that and your self-awareness and your, you know, your interdynamics between even your team. It's really important stuff. And, you know, I think that's what's coming across loud and clear is that you're really in Salford, you're asking for the skills that are I think key to being effective in a psychology role I think from my perspective as well from Anna coming through and from subsequent
而我当时并没有意识到，这一切现在已经极大程度地影响了我目前在岗位上的工作方式。现在，获得非癫痫性发作障碍（NED）诊断的过程是如此漫长，患者往往要经历完全漫长的医疗流程，被怀疑可能是癫痫或许多其他疾病。所以，回想起我的申请，汲取我自己在家庭等方面的个人经历，看到医疗“煤气灯操纵”和长期确诊的过程对一个人造成了什么影响……是的，这产生了巨大的影响。我到现在也经常在工作中借鉴这些，这绝对是我注意到的关于这份申请的第一大不同之处。
rounds of AP interviews people have actually fed back that they've found it really useful to take the time to reflect on what their values are and where they've come from because even if they didn't get this particular job or that particular job it's informed what they do further down the line and I say encouraging that was really powerful for us because we'd not done that before we'd focused on skill set you know and academics and so yeah I think I think for us as well from a from a interview as a recruiter side um it felt a bit more inclusive but it felt like a nicer process rather than just starting off with that Q&A you know it is more of a right we've got a sense of
太棒了！这真的太重要了，对吧？就我们这个职业而言，反思并不是当你进入培训期或获得资格后才突然自动发生的。你需要具备这种能力并将其付诸实践，在实践中磨练你的技能、你的自我觉察，以及你与团队之间的互动动力。这些都是非常重要的内容。而我认为，最响亮、最清晰地传达出来的信号是：在索尔福德，你们正在寻找那些对于胜任心理学角色至关重要的核心技能。从我作为招聘者的角度来看，以及从安娜的应聘经历和随后的各轮AP面试中，应聘者们实际上都反馈说，他们发现花时间反思自己的价值观以及自己的根源是非常有用的。因为即使他们没有得到这份或那份特定的工作，这也为他们未来的职业发展奠定了基础。我可以说，这种鼓励对我们来说具有非常强大的力量，因为我们以前从未这样做过。我们以前只专注于技能组合和学术背景。所以，是的，我认为对于我们作为面试官、作为招聘方来说，
them we can use that as a jumping off point now rather than oh they answered that question okay do you know what I mean yeah definitely and it's definitely making me think about my experience of applying for qualified roles in psychology as well and you know seeing them across the same trust literally is just copied and pasted there's not even anything bespoke about that particular role which rather embarrassingly led to me going to an interview thinking that the service was one type of thing. I thought it was an inpatient unit because it said IPU, because nowhere in any of the literature had it discussed what an IPU was. It's actually an integrated practice unit. But because I wasn't already in that trust, how was I to know that?
这感觉更具包容性，而且是一个更好的过程，而不是一上来就进行传统的问答。它更像是一种：“我们已经对他们有了一个整体的了解，现在我们可以以此为跳板深入交流”，而不是“哦，他们回答对了那个问题，下一个。”确实如此！这绝对让我想起了自己过去申请心理学正式岗位的经历。你会在同一个信托基金会的招聘信息中看到完全复制粘贴的内容，甚至连针对该特定岗位的量身定制内容都没有。这让我有些尴尬地犯过一个错误：我去参加面试时，以为该服务是某种特定类型的工作。我以为那是一个住院病房（Inpatient Unit），因为上面写着“IPU”，而任何宣传资料中都没有讨论过“IPU”到底是什么。实际上，它是指“综合诊疗所”（Integrated Practice Unit）。但因为我当时不在那个信托基金会工作，我怎么可能知道呢？
So I went along thinking I was going for an interview for an inpatient unit for 10 to 17 year olds, which I thought was quite cool because I was working in a cam service at the time. But thankfully, I'd gone in for a chat before a couple of days before the interview and I just thought this doesn't seem quite right you know this isn't I'm sure this isn't children and I asked the question you know where are the inpatient units and they gave me some sort of oh like oh you know yeah a few miles away and I was like what what is this job so it made me look awful but actually it's the recruitment processes because it was the copy and paste job description which told you nothing about the role and i think that's something we wanted to speak to as well particularly you know people like anna without
所以我去面试时，以为自己是在申请一个面向10到17岁青少年的住院病房面试。我觉得这挺酷的，因为当时我正在儿童和青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）工作。但谢天谢地，在面试前几天我去参加了一个交流聊天，当时我就觉得：“这好像不太对劲啊，这根本……我确信这不是儿童病房。”于是我问了他们：“住院病房在哪里？”他们给我的回答模棱两可，比如：“哦……在几英里外。”我说：“等等，那这到底是什么工作？”这让我显得糟糕透顶。但实际上，这是招聘流程本身的问题，因为它是复制粘贴的职位描述，对该岗位的工作内容闭口不谈。我想这也是我们想要探讨的问题，特别是对于像安娜这样之前没有AP经验的人来说：什么是AP？那份工作到底是干什么的？什么是反思？一份申请表到底应该长什么样？所以我想，当我们在构思这种新型招聘方式时，我们并不是第一个尝试其中某些做法的人。我们借鉴了其他职位的描述和其他人的创意，
the ap experience before what's an ap you know what does that job look like what's reflection what's an application supposed to look like so that's where i suppose when we're thinking about our novel recruiting we we're not the first to do some of these things we've pulled on other job descriptions and pulled on other ideas uh particularly from the likes of the i suppose class clinical psych on on on twitter and will curvis from up at lanks lx have done a lot of interesting stuff around that, but we thought, well, actually let's put a supplementary document on here, which talks about the department. Let's get one of our APs to write a few paragraphs as to what her day looks
特别是来自推特上的“Class Clinical Psych”账号，以及兰开夏郡勒克斯（Lancs Lex）的威尔·柯维斯（Will Curvis）等人的创意。他们围绕这个主题做了许多非常有趣的工作。但我们觉得，实际上，我们应该在上面附上一份补充文件，详细介绍我们的部门。让我们的一位AP写几段话，描述她的一天是什么样的。让我们把对招聘流程的期望告诉应聘者，好让他们能按这种方式来撰写。而不是像盲人摸象那样试探着说：“我不知道，但我还是把这个交了吧”或者像许多招过很多人的人那样，把上一份申请的内容复制粘贴到下一份里。这其实是在探讨：我们如何在不让应聘者感到“哦，我得赶紧把申请交上去，因为他们马上要截止了”的前提下，引导大家写出我们真正想要的东西？所以，是的，我想
like. Let's tell them what we want for our process so they can write it in that way. Rather than dipping your toe in the water and going oh i don't know but i'm just going to send this or i've recruited a lot of people cut and paste the application from one into another you know it's trying to how do we how do we i suppose guide people to what we want without them thinking oh i need to get this application in asap because they'll close it so yeah i think
就像我说的，最初迈出的一大步是试图改变我们的职位描述和个人能力要求。我们去掉了将理学硕士（MSc）作为“理想条件”的做法；我们去掉了对2:1学位硬性要求的执念——虽然我们理解许多临床心理学项目仍将2:1设为最低标准，但我们认为，除非你了解为什么有人会拿2:2或2:1，否则它仅仅代表了一种较高水平的学术运作能力。我们不在乎A-level成绩，A-level已经是很久以前的事了。我们还希望强调这样一个事实：你不需要拥有临床经验才能具备相关经验。所以，改变这一点对我们信托基金会来说并不是那么难，我们在支持下做到了。
i think like say the the the big first up stuff was trying to change our job description and person specs so we we dropped the msc as being desirable um desirable criteria we dropped sort of two one we appreciate that a lot of declines say 2.1 minimum but we're like well actually unless you know why people got a 2.2 or 2.1 it's it's still a high level of academic functioning we don't care about A-levels, A-levels are a long time ago we also wanted to i suppose speak up the fact that you don't need to have had clinical experience to have relevant experience um so changing that wasn't for us in our trust that wasn't that hard we were able to do that with support um adding the supplementary document was relatively easy once we sort of talked about well it was easy once we got the
添加补充文件也相对容易，一旦我们讨论并确定了……其实，一旦我们把专业术语和措辞敲定下来，事情就变得容易了。这可能是最难的部分：思考什么话可以说，什么话不能说；什么叫过于引导，什么叫引导不够。所以希望我们并不总是能做到百分之百完美，人们也可能会觉得某些表述不太合适，但在现阶段，我们已经尽最大努力做到最好了。正如你在社交媒体上可能也看到的，我们希望为这些职位赋予“人情味”，将名字与面孔对应起来。所以在招聘启事发布后，我们举办了网络研讨会，人们可以免费拨入参与。再次强调，通过这种方式，他们可以了解我们的部门，了解他们将要与什么样的人共事，了解这些人的心路历程是怎样的、他们平时都做些什么。这让整个过程变得更加人性化、
terminology uh i suppose signed off that was probably the hardest thing think about what's what's okay to say what's not okay to say what's sort of too leading what's um not leading enough you know so hopefully we don't get it right every time and people might not think that's appropriate but we've tried to be as good as possible at this moment in time um and i suppose you will have seen on on social media as well we we kind of wanted to put names to faces so we we've run webinars to um in the middle once the job's out we've offered a webinar that people can dial into for free and again hear about our department but also the people who are going to be working with what's their journey like what do they do um making a bit more personable
更容易接近。因为我想，作为其中的一部分，每个人都想谈论自己的心路历程，因为每个人的经历都是独一无二的。人们可能会看到我目前处于这个职位，听到我的口音，然后心想：“哦，他是一个享有特权的白人男性。”嗯，现在这可能是真的，但我的家庭可能曾付出过极其艰辛的努力才把我推到这个位置上。我仍然是家族里第一代上大学的人，但如果你只是与我见个面，你是绝对看不出这一点的。然而，如果你询问我的价值观，你可能会对我有更多了解。所以，是的，这只是其中的一些事情。我想我可能已经大大偏离了我们最初讨论的话题。但我觉得，我们感到欣慰的是，我们现在更有信心觉得自己在做正确的事情，并且以一种全面、圆融的方式来培养人才，而不是流水线式地招进一个又一个彼此雷同的AP。
and accessible um because i suppose as a part of this everyone wants to talk about their journey because everyone's is different you know people might see me in my position and hear my accent and think oh well he's a privileged white male well that may be true right now but my family might have worked very hard to put me in a position uh i'm still a first generation university attender but you wouldn't see that from from meeting me but if you ask me about my values you'll probably find out a bit more you know um so yeah there were just a few of the things I suppose I might have deviated massively for what we're talking about initially. But I think we feel, I suppose, comfortable in the fact that we feel more like we're doing the right sort of thing now and bringing through people in a nicely rounded way rather than getting AP1 who's just like AP2, who's just like AP3, you know. Yeah, and I think you're adding the humanity, the compassion, reducing the ambiguity and the anxiety as well. You know, you're saying this is,
是的，我认为你们为招聘过程增添了人性、同情心，同时也减少了模糊性和焦虑感。你知道，你们传递的信息是：“这就是我们认为有可能成为优秀心理学家的人所具备的特质，但这可能并不符合你过去习惯用来衡量自己的那些传统标准。”你也提到了申请人数的问题。我过去绝对属于那种在通勤路上看到NHS Jobs（NHS招聘网站）邮件提醒的人。我年纪比较大啦，所以会在上班前收到一封新职位提醒邮件，当时你会想：“太棒了，我今晚回家就把这个申请了。”但结果呢，我和那些没有工作、在我上班期间就已经投递了申请的人在竞争。所以等我下班回家准备申请时，该职位在短短几个小时内就已经关闭了。你们的申请者配额增加了吗？
this is, you know, the kind of people that we think might potentially be able to be great psychologists, but it might not be the, you know, the kind of criteria that you're used to measuring yourself up against. And you touched on application numbers as well. I definitely was in the camp where you'd be, you know, you'd see on NHS jobs, perhaps on your way to work, where you get an email. I was quite old. So it's like, I get an email before I went to work that there was an alert, you know, and you think, oh, brilliant, I'll get home tonight and I'll do that but then I was competing against people who haven't got jobs and had applied while I was at work and so by the time I got home to be able to apply the job had closed you know within a few hours. Have you increased your quota of applicants uh yeah we we've tried to uh speak to that really we we left
是的，我们确实试图解决这个问题。我们将招聘广告开放了两周，这是一个相当标准的时长，我们并没有对人数设定上限。但我想我们需要做的是，确保对于英国健康教育局（HEE）资助的岗位，有某种形式的筛选机制来确保人们符合资格。所以，在“Trac”（NHS广泛使用的招聘平台）上，你在那个阶段可以设置几个问题。因此，是的，当我们将职位发布到Trac上时，有一个选项可以设置一些筛选问题。我们在其中加入了一些与岗位高度相关的问题，比如：你是否有过相关经验？你是否已经毕业？你是否具备注册资格的基础（GBC）？因为如果你没有这些，我们可能会收到成百上千份申请。同样，我们也在努力确保人们花时间阅读招聘广告和补充信息，因为我们希望他们按照我们的要求来撰写申请。我知道这听起来有点傻，但我们不希望有人直接点击“发送”，我们希望他们了解我们，了解我们的需求。所以我们确实做了一些可能总体上会减少申请人数的事情——天哪，如果什么都不做，我们真不知道会收到多少申请。这是一个很难回答的问题，但你知道的，我们仅仅对经过初步筛选的候选人就收到了130份申请。所以，这样做是正确的。虽然在处理后续环节时花去了更多的时间，但我们认为这非常符合我们身处的行业精神，符合我们去扶持、培养人才的理念。
the job open for two weeks pretty standard we didn't cap it at a certain number but i suppose what we did need to do is make sure that for the health education england post that there was some sort of screening that people were eligible so on on track which is the i suppose the platform that you use a lot in the nhs you put a few questions at that point um um so yeah when we put it on track there's the option to do some screening questions so we had a few in there that were very relevant to the post and that was have you had any previous experience have you graduated have you got graduate basis for registration because if you don't have those we could have got hundreds and hundreds similarly we were also trying to make sure that people took the time
所以，是的，这个过程可能会更冗长，但我们对此投入了心力，所以这是值得的。是的，而且我认为
to read the job advert read the supplementary information because we wanted them to write the application as we've asked and i know it sounds daft but we don't want someone to just press send straight away want them to get to know us and get to know what we want so we did do some things that might have reduced the numbers overall god forbid what we'd have got if we'd have just not done anything it's a difficult thing to say but you know we had a 130 applicants for one post and they were the ones that we'd screened you know so it was it was the right thing to do it it took more time when it came to the other side of things but i think it just feels appropriate for the profession we're in and try and in the ethos of of uh i suppose bringing people up um so yeah it was it can be longer winded but we're invested in it so that's okay yeah and i think
去阅读招聘广告、阅读补充信息，因为我们希望他们按照我们的要求来写申请。我知道这听起来有点傻，但我们不希望有人直接点击发送，我们希望他们了解我们，了解我们的需求。所以我们确实做了一些可能总体上会减少申请人数的事情。天哪，如果我们什么都不做的话，真不知道会收到多少申请。这很难说，但你知道的，我们一个岗位收到了130份申请，而这些还只是通过初筛的。所以，这样做是正确的。虽然在另一阶段花费了更多时间，但我觉得这非常符合我们所处的行业精神，也契合我们那种扶持新人的理念。所以，是的，过程可能会更啰嗦，但我们愿意投入时间，所以这没问题，而且我认为
having sometimes been in trainee roles and assistant roles and even qualified roles sometimes you can just feel like you know another donut on the production line. Whereas you saying, you know, I'm actually okay with giving a day to screen and look at these 100 applications, because I want to make sure that we're a good fit for you. And that you're a good fit for us. That's just about respect and, you know, treating each employee is really important, because you don't want someone to be in a role six months and disappear you want them to love the job but you also want to love them in the job and so that they can stay for a longer period of time and get the best for themselves but the best for you guys too yeah I'll quickly speak to that because I'd like to get Anna's opinion on this as well but yeah I think we're wanting to
有时担任过培训角色、助理角色甚至合格的角色，你有时会觉得自己就像生产线上的另一个甜甜圈。而你说，你知道吗，我其实愿意花一天时间筛选和查看这100份申请，因为我想确保我们对你来说是一个很好的匹配，并且你对我们来说也是一个很好的匹配。这只是关于尊重，你知道的，真正重视每一位员工，因为你不想让某人在岗位上呆了六个月就消失了，你希望他们热爱这份工作，但也希望你们在工作中也爱他们，这样他们才能呆更长的时间，为自己争取到最好的结果，同时也为你们争取到最好的结果。是的，我会快速谈谈这一点，因为我也想听听安娜对这方面的看法，但是的，我想我们希望把
pull people through into neuropsychology and neuropsychology sometimes people think well it's all about testing and numbers I suppose you wanted to put a bit more freedom inside on our profession as well but we've got a really good record at Salford of bringing people through as APs who maybe come back to us as trainees but if trainees come in they often come back to us as qualified and we we really like that I suppose that loyalty and that culture within our department um so hopefully this just adds to something we've got already but yeah it'd be interesting to hear Anna's opinion because I'm very biased because I've been in that department since I qualified yeah no definitely and just to add as well on what you
人们吸引到神经心理学领域，有时人们会认为神经心理学就是关于测试和数字的，我想你们也希望为我们的职业带来更多的自由度，但我们在索尔福德有一个非常好的记录，就是把人们培养成助理心理学家（AP），他们可能会作为实习生回到我们这里，但如果实习生进来，他们经常会作为合格人员回到我们这里，我们真的非常喜欢这种忠诚度以及我们部门内的这种文化，嗯，所以希望这能为我们现有的东西增添一些色彩，但是的，听到安娜的看法会很有趣，因为我非常偏心，因为我从合格起就一直在这个部门工作，是的，不，绝对是的，而且就像你刚才说的
just said before Alistair I hadn't actually thought about the brochure that you'd put together um the team had put together for the application um but actually that section in there about the sort of day in the life of an AP was really really insightful and obviously nothing something that we'd never really seen before um I think I'm in loads of different Facebook groups of all assistant psychologists sharing for sort of what their job does and giving each other advice on interviews and things like that but to actually see it written out to see if it was a role you'd be interested in yourself and I think that was reflected in the webinar as well because when you're at this point, as both of you have mentioned, sort of trying to get into your first assistant post and making lots of different applications, you forget as much as actually, is this a job experience I need so I think having those stages and having that sort of
在前面提到的那样，艾利斯塔，我之前实际上并没有想到你们为申请准备的那份手册，嗯，团队为申请准备的，但实际上里面关于“助理心理学的一天”那一部分真的非常有启发性，显然这是我们以前从未真正见过的东西，嗯，我想我在各种不同的Facebook群里，里面所有的助理心理学家都在分享他们的工作内容，并就面试等方面互相提供建议，但实际上看到它被写出来，看看这是否是你自己会感兴趣的角色，我想这也体现在网络研讨会中，因为正如你们俩所提到的，当你处于这个阶段，试图进入你的第一个助理岗位并做出大量不同的申请时，你就会忘记，实际上，这真的是我需要的职业经验吗？所以我想拥有这些阶段和拥有这种
webinar explaining sort of the trust values and the department and seeing who you'd be working with and things like that it's as much about understanding whether you'd want to work for that team just as much as do I absolutely want this job so yeah but as far as once you're actually in the department yeah it's what i said about touched on before just it's not um it's not as much about yeah it just wasn't as much of a jump as what i'd expected it obviously is neuropsychology and um while i'm not sort of doing testing and things like that as much at the moment, the support is there from supervision is amazing. There's lots of clinicians, even if outside of your supervision,
解释信托价值观和部门并了解你将与谁共事的网络研讨会，这既是为了了解你是否愿意为那个团队工作，也是为了了解我是否绝对想要这份工作，所以是的，但就你真正进入部门而言，是的，就像我之前提到的那样，它并不，它并不像我预期的那样是一个巨大的飞跃，它显然是神经心理学，嗯，虽然我目前没有做太多测试之类的事情，但督导提供的支持是惊人的。有很多临床医生，甚至在你的督导之外，
it's a very close-knit department and there's lots of opportunity to work with and sort of consult other clinicians about things. And as well, the peer supervision, I think is a massive thing um in the department there's lots of assistance and um yeah I think definitely sort of peer reflection and peer supervision is one thing that I potentially hadn't really thought about as much before um but I'm not sure I could um yeah it definitely makes the role a lot easier having that support there from from other people who are going through your experiences. It really does I was fortunate to also be part of a very large team of assistant psychologists and it was just incredible you know even being able to have really informal chats over lunch was just really really powerful stuff
这是一个非常紧密的部门，有很多机会与同行工作并就某些事情咨询其他临床医生。而且，同伴督导，我认为是部门里的一个巨大亮点，嗯，有很多助理，嗯，是的，我认为同伴反思和同伴督导绝对是我以前可能没有真正多想的一件事，但我不知道我是否能，嗯，有来自其他经历过你经历的人的支持，这确实让这个角色变得容易得多。确实如此，我很幸运能加入一个非常庞大的助理心理学家团队，这简直太不可思议了，你知道，甚至能够在大快朵颐时进行非常随意的聊天，也是非常非常强大的事情
and then I then went to a role where I was the only assistant psychologist I just felt so lonely in comparison I didn't even have a desk or like a chair like it was really really difficult so yeah absolutely a lot to be gained from peer supervision and just companionship at the same level of journey that you're at as well could you tell us briefly whether the interview was any different to ones you you'd been to before Anna yeah definitely so in between actually the written application and the interview there was a video submission so I'll just touch on that briefly as well because um that was completely novel to me I'd never done that before um and probably if I was to reflect on how I felt at the time it
然后我去了另一个角色，我是唯一的助理心理学家，相比之下我感到非常孤独，我甚至没有办公桌或椅子，这真的非常非常困难，所以是的，绝对有很多东西可以从同伴督导和处于相同旅程阶段的陪伴中获得，你能简要告诉我们面试是否与你以前去过的面试有什么不同吗，安娜？是的，绝对的，所以在书面申请和面试之间实际上有一个视频提交，所以我也会简单提及这一点，因为嗯，这对我是全新体验，我从来没有做过，并且如果我要反思当时的感觉，
was maybe a bit awkward about having to do that um but and as well I think when you are sort of an aspiring clinician or when you are a clinician you'd like to think that you hold a lot of values so trying to refine it just to a select few that really mean something to you but also you think um would fit well within the the team that you might be working in and the trust um that was really interesting i think as well there's only so many so much you can put in words um so it was able sort of gave you the opportunity to get across some more non-verbal skills so showing um your enthusiasm and giving a bit more of your personality across I think was really valuable about having that stage as well um and even sort of like common factor
可能有点尴尬，因为必须这样做，但是，并且还有，我想当你是一个有抱负的临床医生或者当你是一个临床医生时，你会认为你秉持着很多价值观，所以试图将其提炼为对你真正有意义的少数几个，同时你也认为嗯，会很好地融入你可能工作的团队和信托中，这真的很有趣，我也认为，你能用言语表达的东西是有限的，所以它能够给你提供机会传达更多非语言技能，比如展现嗯你的热情并表达出你更多的个性，我认为拥有这个阶段也非常有价值，并且甚至像共同因素
skills so like body language and and tone of voice and um even down to sort of thinking about your background if you're doing um virtual sessions and things like that so yeah that that video stage was another um another good one and then the interview stage so they went I think you refer to it um as a selection event Alistair didn't you yeah I'm guessing a lot um yeah so yeah so the selection event um in it's nothing I'd ever experienced before I'd had a few different interviews for um psychology jobs and non-psychology jobs um and I think in more of the business career you hear about um assessment center days and things like that but I interviews had always been a one one-on-one um experience for me I'd never sort of been able to see essentially who you're up against in that situation um so going into that group so I'll explain how they did it um so it
技能，比如肢体语言和语调，嗯，甚至考虑到如果你在做虚拟会议等情况下的背景，所以是的，视频阶段是另一个嗯很好的阶段，然后是面试阶段，所以他们去过，我想你提到过，埃利斯塔，你称之为选择活动，不是吗？是的，我猜很多，是的，所以是的，所以选择活动，这是我从未经历过的，我曾为心理学工作和非心理学工作进行过几次不同的面试，我想在更多的商业职业中，你会听说评估中心日之类的事情，但我的面试对我来说总是一对一的体验，我从来没有能够看到你在那种情况下究竟在跟谁竞争，所以进入那个小组，所以我会解释他们是怎么做的，所以它
was two groups I think of maybe five um applicants and one clinician um in each call maybe an assistant as well it's a bit of a blur now. But yeah, and they asked one question, basically put it up for debate in the first group and sort of gave the floor to us to have a discussion about it. And then in the next group, it was a different question. So I think thinking about the questions themselves, they definitely mimicked the inclusive process because I'd prepared, I think, so much about neuropsychology and was quite worried maybe that it was going to be very, very neuro. I do have neuro experience from what I'd done in my undergrad, but that was the most recent thing. But actually, they were sort of based around ethical dilemmas. And I think as well, the other one was more of like a contemporary issue. So it was something that you could absolutely answer if you're a person who's gone through this process
是两组，每组可能有五个左右的申请人和一个临床医生，每个通话中可能还有一个助理，现在有点模糊了。但是，是的，他们提出了一个问题，基本上在第一组中将其提出来讨论，并把发言权交给我们进行讨论。然后在下一组中，这是一个不同的问题。所以我想思考问题本身，它们绝对模仿了包容性过程，因为我想我为神经心理学做了很多准备，并且很担心它会非常非常侧重于神经科学。我从本科所做的事情中确实有神经科学经验，那是我最近做的事情。但实际上，它们是围绕道德困境展开的。我想还有另一个更像是当代问题的话题，所以如果你是一个经历过这个过程的人，你绝对可以回答这个问题
and who doesn't have prior experience in neuropsychology or a prior assistant post so yeah even just the questions um were a good good um learning experience but also not they kind of fell in line with what was expected um but then the actual process of of being in these group situations um I actually really enjoyed I think you're so eager in an interview to show off all your knowledge and um think about all of your previous experiences and things like that but actually this is kind of similar to the um video stage where it just gave you more of an opportunity to show off a whole other range of skills so it was as much about answering the question and
并且之前没有神经心理学或助理岗位经验的人，所以是的，即使只是这些问题也是一个很好的学习经验，而且它们也符合预期，但是处于这些小组情况下的实际过程，我其实真的很享受，我想你在面试中是如此急于展示你所有的知识，并思考你之前所有的经验等等，但实际上这有点类似于视频阶段，它只是给了你更多的机会来展示一整套其他的技能，所以它既关乎回答问题，又
showing like demonstrating your knowledge and and demonstrating sort of how you come to your answer and different things like that but I think actually it was just as much about demonstrating sort of your interpersonal skills and your non-verbal feedback and sort of active listening skills and it was interesting to see actually how it was I feel just as much about letting others speak so as I said you want to show off everything you know but equally you're in a group situation so yeah I think it's it's an opportunity where you can really show compassion for others and allowing other people to demonstrate their skills as well and give their opinions um yeah now I was just gonna say sort of um validating um validating other people's thoughts and adding
展示你的知识，并展示你如何得出答案以及各种不同的事情，但我认为实际上它同样关乎展示你的软技能、非语言反馈和积极倾听技能，而且有趣的是，看到它是如何让其他人发言的，正如我所说，你想炫耀你知道的一切，但同样你身处一个小组环境中，所以是的，我认为这是一个你可以真正向他人展示同情心并允许其他人也展示他们的技能并发表意见的机会，嗯，现在我要说的是，嗯，验证，验证其他人的想法并添加
on them if you had anything else to add sorry it's really nice here from my side yeah it's okay if I just um I suppose what you've got here is Anna's perspective. And what's really nice for me is Anna and I haven't really spoken about this, but how it works in parallel with what we wanted to do. You know, the asking the applicants to submit a short three minute video, talk about values with also a link to an online resource where you can do a value sorting exercise in line with acceptance and commitment therapy it's kind of in line with therapeutic approaches it's kind of line with sort of theories and we got a sense of seeing what do they look like what do they how do they talk about this what's their experience and so that was really useful we
如果你有什么要补充的话，抱歉，从我这边听起来真的很棒。是的，如果我只是，嗯，我想你在这里得到的是安娜的视角。对我来说非常棒的是，安娜和我并没有真正讨论过这一点，但它如何与我们想要做的事情并行运作。你知道，要求申请人提交一段短短的三分钟视频，谈论价值观，并附上一个在线资源的链接，在那里你可以做一个与接纳承诺疗法相一致的价值观排序练习，这有点符合治疗方法，这有点符合某种理论，我们了解到他们看起来是什么样子的，他们是如何谈论这一点的，他们的经验是什么，所以这非常有用，我们
used that actually as um we'd long listed and this was our short listing uh way of going about it so getting people down to that last sort of 10 12 it was something like that wasn't i know it wasn't a massive group but that was a really useful thing for us because we we were able to send it to them so it was pre-prepared it wasn't as well it was probably anxiety provoking in a very different way but it was pre-prepared it wasn't as well it was probably anxiety provoking in a very different way but it was um something that we wanted to try because we never tried it before it gave us a chance to think about it over time and confer with each other about what we wanted but i think we wouldn't be able to do it without using the again i referenced it previously
实际上用它作为，我们进行了长名单筛选，这是我们进行筛选的方式，让人数缩减到最后大约10到12人，大概是这样的，我知道这不是一个庞大的群体，但这对我们来说是一件非常有用的事情，因为我们能够把它发给他们，所以它是预先准备好的，它不是，它可能以一种非常不同的方式引发焦虑，但它是预先准备好的，它不是，它可能以一种非常不同的方式引发焦虑，但它是，嗯，这是我们想要尝试的事情，因为我们以前从未尝试过，这让我们有机会随着时间的推移考虑它，并互相商量我们想要什么，但我认为如果不使用，我之前提到过，
the langsteeinton sci competency framework which is publicly available so it's not something that's a secret but we wanted to use something from a course that's quite inclusive already um so it just enabled us to i suppose uh start thinking about things in terms of competencies not experiences and skills explicitly um yeah and then similarly we wanted to go down the line of perhaps what to call an interview we didn't want to call it assessment center so selection event became our terminology and yeah so we had like um one qualified and and one assistant in each group so we've almost got someone at a peer level who sort of you know i'm a fair way away from being an ap i don't know
朗斯顿·西（Langsteeinton Sci）能力框架，它是公开可用的，所以它不是什么秘密，但我们希望使用来自已经相当具有包容性的课程的东西，所以它使我们能够，我想，开始从能力而不是明确的经验和技能的角度来思考事情，是的，然后类似地，我们想沿着也许称之为面试的路线走下去，我们不想称之为评估中心，所以选择活动成了我们的术语，是的，所以我们在每个小组中都有一个合格人员和一个助理，所以我们几乎有一个同行水平的人，你知道的，我距离AP还有很长一段路，我不知道
as much as what it's like it's good to have someone else's perspective on that and then almost like swapping and then sort of re-rating based on the competencies and then I think we had just a very brief interview in the afternoon and that was interestingly I think that was me and Selena going we've got to do some sort of one-on-one because that's what we always do and I think in hindsight it was relatively useful but I don't think it added as much as we'd thought because we'd actually got more than enough from the other two so I think in this next round of this funding we're not going to do that we're going to perhaps just add a little bit to the video rather than having another interview element um but yeah i'm really it's really nice to hear
它是什么样的，有另一个人的视角是很好的，然后几乎就像交换一样，然后根据能力重新评分，然后我想我们在下午有一个非常简短的面试，有趣的是，我认为那是我和塞莱娜在说，我们得做某种一对一的面试，因为我们总是这么做，而且事后看来，我认为它相对有用，但我认为它并没有增加我们想象的那么多，因为我们实际上从其他两个环节中得到了绰绰有余的信息，所以我想在这个资助轮次中，我们不会这样做，我们可能只是在视频中添加一点内容，而不是再有一个面试环节，但是的，我真的，听到
anna talking about the group discussions because we didn't know how that was going to go we wanted something um that would be supportive so not he who shouts loudest but actually how do people interact how do they work in a group situation because again a lot of things i was thinking about with this process is we want people to go to the declan so they need to show declan competencies and if they work if they've already got some of that naturally from their context then we can go and work towards that so i think it was really nice i'd been to declan interviews where they'd done group tasks and I thought I'd done a really good job.
安娜谈论小组讨论感觉真的很棒，因为我们不知道事情会怎样发展，我们需要一些，嗯，能够提供支持的东西，所以不是谁喊得最大声，而是人们如何互动，他们如何在小组情况下工作，因为同样，我通过这个过程思考的很多事情是，我们希望人们去德克兰，所以他们需要表现出德克兰的能力，如果他们从他们的背景中自然地拥有其中的一些，那么我们就可以去朝着那个方向努力，所以我想这真的很棒，我曾去过德克兰面试，他们做过小组任务，我以为我做得很好。
And actually, I'd done a good job at answering the question, but had I done a good job of including other people? Perhaps not. So I think for me, that was a really nice adjunct to what we've done and we'll do that, well, we're going to do that this time around. We won't tell you what the ethical dilemmas are yet because there might be people listening that have applied. Yeah, thank you so much for helping illuminate some of those processes
事实上，我在回答问题方面做得很好，但我有没有做好把其他人包容进来的工作？可能没有。所以我想对我来说，这真的是我们所做事情的一个很好的补充，我们也会这样做，好吧，我们这次打算这样做。我们还不会告诉你道德困境是什么，因为可能会有已经申请的人在听。是的，非常感谢你帮助阐明其中的一些过程
um and yeah i've definitely done a group task um as part of a couple of my declines i interviews actually but definitely got a sense if it's not the ones who speak up the most who are the ones that are going to necessarily be invited um to be part of the cohort so yeah i think it's very interesting food for thought um just a little bit conscious of the cohort so yeah I think it's very interesting food for thought just a little bit conscious of the time and I wonder if either or both of you could just offer a top a few top tips for any organizations or trusts who might be looking to try and implement some more modern inclusive recruitment processes. I suppose Anna and I'm probably putting you on the spot here but I suppose you'll be the type of person that's applying for these jobs what sort of things
嗯，是的，我确实在我的几个德克兰面试中做过小组任务，但肯定有一种感觉，即如果不是那些最常发言的人，他们不一定是被邀请成为队列一部分的人，所以是的，我认为这是非常有趣的深思熟虑，只是对队列有一点意识，所以是的，我想这是非常有趣的深思熟虑，只是对时间有一点意识，我想知道你们中的一个或两个是否可以为任何可能正在寻找尝试实施更多现代包容性招聘流程的组织或信托机构提供一些最重要的建议。我想安娜，我可能在这里把你架在火上烤了，但我想你会是那种申请这些工作的人，你希望看到什么样的事情
would you want to see that would make you want to work for that trust that firm or apply for that course? I think I do value a lot sort of speaking to current assistants if they have them in their service and understanding what it is about their job that they do what it is about their job that they enjoy um and sort of reflecting that maybe a little bit in in the recruitment process um just trying to think of some other things um i think as well yeah having having different options so like with this process not just basing it all on written um whether it's a video or whether it's i think anything else um even like a presentation i think can be valuable so just having some sort of other aspect that's that's more of like a verbal verbal form but yeah that's that's what I'd say
会让你想为那个信托机构、那家公司工作或申请那门课程？我想我确实很重视与现有的助理交谈，如果他们的服务中有这些人的话，并了解他们的工作内容是什么，他们喜欢他们工作的什么，嗯，并在招聘过程中可能稍微反映这一点，只是试图想一些其他的事情，我也认为，是的，有不同的选择，就像这个过程一样，不仅仅完全基于书面，无论是视频还是无论是别的什么，我想其他任何事情，甚至像演示文稿，我认为都是有价值的，所以只需拥有某种其他更像口头形式的方面，但是的，这就是我想说的
I suppose I know you're a little bit biased because you went through this and did well out of it but that's really nice to hear from from my side i think i think i suppose my my top tips would be to perhaps um i suppose be less worried about being doing something different um i think what we're trying to do is make this a bit of a new norm rather than uh something that's novel and lesser seen so you know we we've done a lot of hard work but we've based that on other people's hard work as well so i mean what we're doing we're sharing it's not something we're protective about we're not we're not sort of trying to get the best of the best we're just trying to do things in a right way so i think thinking more about what's important in clinical psychology rather than i
我想我知道你有点偏心，因为你经历了这一切并且做得很好，但从我这边听到这些真的很棒，我想，我想我的头号建议可能是，嗯，少担心去做一些不同的事情，我认为我们试图做的是让这成为一种新的常态，而不是一种新颖且少见的现象，所以你知道，我们做了很多艰苦的工作，但我们也以其他人的艰苦工作为基础，所以我的意思是，我们正在做的事情，我们正在分享，这不是我们保守的东西，我们不是，我们不是试图获得最好的中的最好，我们只是试图以正确的方式做事，所以我想更多地思考临床心理学中什么才是重要的，而不是
suppose what skills and experiences do you need what sort of person do you want is going to be important you know draw on that act stuff um i think i think what we've tried to speak to video submissions or sometimes asking them giving um the as a question or two or letting them know we want you to present on your values for two minutes in the interview that that helps because I'm sure as Anna spoke about she prepped she prepped for perhaps questions she thought might come up well if we tell you what the question is it gives you something a bit more focused there will still be some things that we kind of want to test you on but i think giving some nod to the fact that you guys should know something um should give a bit of a heads up it can help people feel less anxious uh for people
我想你需要什么技能和经验，你想成为什么样的人将是很重要的，利用那些ACT的东西，我想，我想我们试图谈论视频提交，或者有时要求他们这样做，给出一个或两个问题，或者让他们知道我们希望你在面试中花两分钟展示你的价值观，这会有帮助，因为我确信正如安娜所说，她为她认为可能会出现的问题做好了准备，如果我们告诉你问题是什么，它会给你一些更专注的东西，仍然会有一些我们想要测试你的东西，但我认为对你们应该知道一些事情这一事实给予一些肯定，应该能给人们打个预防针，它可以帮助人们减少焦虑，对于
uh perhaps on the autistic spectrum it it it reduces some of the stress from that side of things because it's something that's not as uncertain as it once was. So, yeah, I would definitely try and engage with, I suppose, the EDI team. I try and link it to trust values if you're trying to sell it to your managers, because there's usually something about inclusion and diversity at this moment in time. But, yeah, I just share, share, share. I think it's it feels to me like good practice at this moment I think uh Anna and myself and a couple of colleagues might try and write this up as a bit more of a practice-based example so again in the future people can say well here's the research on it rather than just this guy's done a pod you know incredible and that's going to be so fascinating to read um if people until it's
嗯，可能处于自闭症谱系的人，它减少了这方面的一些压力，因为它是没有那么不确定的事情，曾经是那样。所以，是的，我绝对会尝试参与，我想，EDI团队。如果你想把它推销给你的经理，我试着把它与信托价值观联系起来，因为目前通常有一些关于包容性和多样性的东西。但是，是的，我只分享，分享，分享。在我看来，这就像是目前的良好实践，我认为，嗯，安娜和我以及一些同事可能会试着把这写下来，作为一个更基于实践的例子，以便将来人们可以说，好吧，这里有关于它的研究，而不仅仅是这家伙做了一个播客，你知道的，这真是不可思议，而且阅读起来会非常着迷，如果人们在它
published um did want to get hold of your um of the steps you've been through how's the best way for them to do that alistair uh yeahiger at nca.nhs.uk. So if any, I suppose, professionals wanting to change recruitment processes are interested, I appreciate some star and clinical sites might start getting in contact. So I'll be prepared for that um but yeah feel free to ask a question we've got some stuff we can just send out um without i suppose as long as there's an acknowledgement we've done some work on it that's fine we're not going to be precious you know brilliant thank you so much and i'll make sure i pop all those details in the show
出版之前，想要获取你们的，你们所经历的步骤，获取这些信息的最好方法是什么，埃利斯塔？是的，iger@nca.nhs.uk。所以，如果有任何，我想，想要改变招聘流程的专业人士感兴趣，我很感激一些星级和临床站点可能会开始联系。所以我为此做好准备，但是的，请随时提问，我们有一些东西可以直接发送出去，不用，我想，只要承认我们在这方面做过一些工作就可以了，我们不会太珍视，你知道的，太棒了，非常感谢，我会确保把所有这些细节都放在节目中
notes so that people can readily and easily get hold of them thank you so much for your time and for all of the work that's gone into all of these processes for helping aspiring psychologists have a different journey that feels more humane that feels more like part of the career they want to be part of rather than just you know a faceless number um so yeah it's incredible work really inspiring and it's definitely an ap role i would have wanted along my journey too thank you so much for your time both of you thank you very much yeah thank you for having us welcome back thank you for watching hope you found that to be as invigorating and interesting as i did to film it. Thank you very much for the time to Dr Alistair and Anna and for helping us get the word out there about these important ways of recruiting in going forward in 2023. So I hope that helps you in terms of thinking about contextual admissions. And if you're an employer, then please do think about how you might be able to use the principles of contextual admissions for your next recruitment, whether that's for qualified or non-qualified staff.
笔记里，以便人们可以随时随地轻松获取它们。非常感谢您的时间和为所有这些流程所做的工作，帮助有志向的心理学家拥有不同的旅程，让他们觉得更有人情味，感觉更像是他们想要成为的职业的一部分，而不仅仅是一个毫无面孔的数字，所以是的，这是不可思议的工作，真的非常鼓舞人心，这绝对是我在我的旅程中也想要的AP角色。非常感谢你们两人的时间，非常感谢，是的，谢谢你们邀请我们。欢迎回来，谢谢观看，希望你觉得它像我拍摄时一样充满活力和有趣。非常感谢阿利斯塔博士和安娜抽出时间，并帮助我们在2023年推广这些重要的招聘方式。所以希望这能在情境录取方面对你有所帮助。如果你是雇主，请考虑如何为你的下一次招聘利用情境录取的原则，无论是针对合格还是不合格的员工。
If you're listening and you'd like to come along and join the free Facebook group, the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent, please do so. Also, don't forget there's the membership and of course, the Clinical Psychologist Collective book and the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book. And if you've read any of those, I'd love it if you'd leave us a review on Amazon. And if you have a few more moments, whether you'd be able to leave me an audio testimonial for use in the podcast would be absolutely lovely. Thank you very much for your time and for being part of my world.
如果你在收听，并想加入免费的Facebook群组，即由玛丽安·特伦特博士创立的“有志向的心理学家社区”，请务必加入。此外，别忘了还有会员资格，当然还有《临床心理学家集锦》和《有志向的心理学家集锦》这两本书。如果你读过其中任何一本，如果你能在亚马逊上给我们留个评论，我会很高兴的。如果你还有几分钟时间，你能否为我留下一个音频感谢信，以便在播客中使用，那将绝对是可爱的。非常感谢您的时间，并成为我世界的一部分。
Take care and I'll catch you very soon. Thank you. Psychologist Collective The Aspiring Psychologist Collective If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no
保重，我们很快再见。谢谢。《临床心理学家集锦》《有志向的心理学家集锦》如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这就是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的《有志向的心理学家播客》。我叫亚娜，我是一名见习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集锦》这本书。我发现所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历真的很有趣。它让我惊叹于通往那里的路线竟然有那么多，而且没有
perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
成为其中一员的完美方式，这让我充满信心，不，我没有做错，并减轻了我自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，以让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会把书放下。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任意句子来发表评论。